police in kazakhstan's largest city
almaty tell state media that dozens of
protesters have been killed in what they
call an attempt to storm administrative
buildings and police stations
explosions and apparent gunshots were
also heard in the city's main square
where reporters say hundreds had
gathered to protest against the
government kazakhstan's president has
asked for help and russia will lead an
alliance of former soviet states in
dispatching what they call peacekeeping
forces to help quell the unrest
the protests were triggered by surging
fuel prices
night falls
and the unrest in almaty intensifies
further
what began as a protest against fuel
prices has quickly spiraled out of
control
local media reports that several
security personnel have died
while flights in and out of almaty have
been cancelled
the president has confirmed that
protesters stormed the airport earlier
on wednesday
the protests originally began over the
weekend in the remote oil hub of
zhanojin
but after the government announced an
end to price caps on fuel the unrest
quickly spread to other cities
now a nationwide state of emergency is
in place
in almaty police have been deployed to
curb the unrest
but tear gas and stun grenades have done
little to dissuade the crowds
neither have hundreds of arrests nor the
imposition of a curfew and movement
restrictions in several regions
kazakh president kasim jamaat takayev
said he would reinstate price controls
but by now protesters are calling for
political change beyond the price of
fuel
in a surprise move president takayev
also sacked the government and took
control of the state security committee
ousting former president and long-time
ruler no sultan nazarbayev
now with takayev solely at the helm he
has called in the military and he says
no matter what he will stay in the
capitol
as the head of state and from today the
president of the security council
i intend to act as tough as possible
kazakhstan's authoritarian government
usually tolerates little real opposition
but this time the protesters anger seems
to have caught the authorities off guard
joining me now is journalist bruce pania
a central asia asia specialist he's
following the story for us uh from
prague bruce the internet has been shut
down in kazakhstan now what is the
latest that you're hearing from your
sources on the ground there
well there seemed to be some partial
restoration of the internet um last
night late late uh i don't know if
they've tried to block it out again you
know you mentioned that russia agreed
that they were going to send
some troops over there to help out and
there's there is a what they're calling
in kazakhstan a and counter terrorism
operation underway and alma t at the
moment so i'm sure that the internet is
down in almaty uh and there's probably a
blackout in some of the other other
nearby regions too some of the big
cities as well so um it's it's been hard
to get information for days out there
and until they
come to the point get to the point where
they think they've restored order in
almaty i would imagine it'd be very
difficult to connect
well the size of the protest it does
does come as a surprise really
how could a small uprise against fuel
prices uh get this serious what's the
background to all this
well there's been similar intentions out
there for quite some time i mean there's
a huge disparity in wealth in that
country uh people connected to the
former president nurse nazarbayev and
his family members have done very well i
mean some of them are billionaires they
own you know luxurious properties in
europe for instance in the middle east
uh you know whereas the average person
is getting by on you know a couple
hundred dollars a month and sometimes in
some cases even less than that um
there's there's been problems with
social benefits over the years working
conditions uh you know so there's really
a whole a whole bowl full of problems
that have been that have come up in the
last few years and and you know this
fuel price hike uh just was the catalyst
you know to set off the whole
for everyone to vent their frustrations
for many many years you know and i
should mention also of course that
takayam came in after nazarbayev
resigned in march 2019
there were expectations on the part of
many people that this was going to be a
new era in kazakhstan but
you know it never it never materialized
uh the government continued to operate
exactly as it did there were no
opposition parties registered uh no real
reforms were implemented in the country
um you know so so people just like i say
got frustrated that after nearly three
years really nothing had changed except
the who was the president of the country
well the so-called collective security
treaty organization will send
peacekeepers now to kazakhstan
at the country's request does that mean
that russian troops will crack down on
the protesters
well it's it's interesting crackdown
might not be exactly the right word
kazakh forces seem to be already working
and you know i want to make clear too
that's as far as i've been able to tell
this is only happening in almaty
kazakhstan's a very big country
uh you know so but um you know the
appearance of russian forces on the
streets of almaty will bring back
horrible memories from the soviet air
without a doubt but it might be enough
to restore help restore calm
in that area but there's a lot of
problems they're going to face for this
in the future uh you know people in
kazakhstan will not be happy that takaya
have had to resort to calling in you
know the csto to help him out um you
know and he's he's framed this late all
of a sudden last night as being the work
of a band of terrorists who were trained
outside the country and there was
absolutely no evidence that that's the
case this appears to be purely a popular
uprising uh you know it's sort of
ridiculous if you look at the pictures
some of these protesters they're oil
workers you know women people like that
how these got to be banned of terrorists
who were trained outside the country i
have no idea but he used that as the
pretext to call in the cso he's going to
pay a price for that for you know the
days months years to come probably
journalists bruce palia there thank you
very much
thank you
you